help us change the culture by buying our
latest single from tim cast records only
ever wanted by clicking the link in the
description below
i want to jump to this story from the
postal millennial i want to talk to you
guys about what uh
what portland is becoming what it is
and i guess why it's important that you
know people get out and vote
not just in the congressional elections
but in your local elections as well
the post manual reports portland street
mob shoots at elderly driver
accidentally kills one of their own
shocking videos emerged on social media
showing scenes of a deadly and fiery
chaos at lawless street occupations in
portland
at one of the street racing takeovers on
sunday night near the expo center
attended by hundreds an elderly men in a
van appeared to be caught in the road
before being violently attacked by an
armed mob
video post on social media shows that as
he desperately attempted to reverse and
drive away while being attacked he
backed into a car
this is where things are getting a man
in the crowd then fires at least 18
rounds at the fleeing van a follow-up
video shows the crowd catching up with
the elderly man who had stopped in a
patch of grass he appeared to be in
shock and was bleeding heavily
there were hundreds of people and cars
in the area participating in an apparent
illegal street takeover i want to show
you this account
it says my boy's lifelong friend was
killed last night at the street takeover
there's a candlelight vigil tonight at 8
p.m at the expo center by please plea uh
by please help get the word out and
please help get candles donated to the
location at eight if you're able to no
bs please respect the family this
individual is abolish ice abolish pigs
burn down the system they say love your
friends be anti-racist don't f nazis
black flags clearly an antifa individual
in portland when andy was saying is a
lot of these people supporting these
takeovers are antifa they're leftists
they want the lawlessness this is what
you get
but you know what for whatever reason
the people of portland keep voting for
it so i don't i don't know if there is a
way to change the minds of individuals
who like that kind of scenario because
that i wouldn't want to live anywhere
near it but if that's the case i don't
see a mending of this country in terms
of the political divide especially with
how the fbi's been treating people it
seems like
an inevitability that there's what a
national divorce a civil war or
something like that or maybe a
revolution if one side doesn't actually
stand up and vote
uh close to home here just last week um
i was uh
on a jog as it were um on the mall and
went up kind of the
the
left side of the capitol hill walkway
right and and it's it's a beautiful just
scene
there's mothers there with with kids in
the carriages and just people having a
good time the next thing i know
um
100
or more
guys come down
on
these
motorized skateboards going 30 40 miles
an hour
with their
helmets and
antifa-like gear i don't know if they
were
um
and it's a wonder somebody didn't get
killed and so i got up to the top of the
hill and the reason why i'm telling you
this story is uh
there's a motorcycle cop up there from
the capitol hill police and i go dude
what the what what's going on here it's
like how do you not do anything about
that isn't that your job
and he tells me that they have orders
directly from pelosi
and bowser
not to not to do anything
okay wow that's
that's what's going on
here tim and the other story they like
it they the other story that caught my
eye was just this week in dc
16th street i think somewhere in
northwest
um an nfl
player
okay
who has to look formidable okay nfl
player
got shot
by two kids
with guns
15 years old they were trying to
carja i mean it's like why how does that
happen if if it's not because
there's no law
here in in the district of columbia or
portland or everywhere in between it's i
mean it happens to be these democrat
cities
have these skyrocketing crime rates
because
that's how they roll and and
that's uh
i got no answers for that do you think
it's a cycle they
no it's not a cycle this is like i think
it's it's i think it's cascading out of
control i mean this is the whole
rudy giuliani thing when when he was uh
first uh coming onto the scene and came
with the james q wilson broken window
theory the idea that
that if you
let you know one broken window go
without repair then you'll get a lot of
broken windows no my thought is that in
democratic cities being soft on crime
gets you elected but then you have a
crime problem but you can't suddenly be
tough on crime because then you'll lose
your seat right
i'm trying to find out who who the heck
these people are who were voting for
these people i mean it's just it's just
what
cities and portland is a great city it
used to be a great used to be a great
city
i'll tell you how it works what is going
on there tim you may have got a better
handle on this and
i mean
people uh people care more about social
conformity than they do about the future
of this country i think that's fairly
obvious i think one of the problem with
cities and this is an i believe an
inevitability i remember when i got
wrongly pulled over in chicago i
couldn't do anything about it what am i
supposed to do cop gave me a ticket and
said ha ha
i wasn't speeding didn't matter he said
tell it to a judge a judge said go screw
myself under 21 my license got suspended
yeah so what happens then is
when you get cops that are using quota
systems or in chicago it's real dark
where they have black sites where
they'll arrest people and bring them
without anyone knowing and beat them
things like that no joke this stuff
happens there was one guy who was
electrocuting people to force
confessions
when you arrest people or give them
tickets
because you need to make money off them
you're criminalizing regular people who
then demand that this stop and they say
we don't want this anymore we want the
police to back off
then you get mayors who had elected and
say okay police back off then crime runs
rampant it's an it's it's a cycle it's
an it's a it's a whirlpool of
destruction this is the crazy thing
about these these ghost quota systems
they claim they don't have we know they
do it we know that in many jurisdictions
there are regular people who are like
hey it's the end of the month better
slow down that's a ridiculous notion but
they want to make money they want it
they want to get money from the
citations and then people say i don't
have cop set around anymore when we talk
about
how the left wants to abolish police and
they have these principal narratives a
lot of their narratives i think are
insane right we learned from say like i
think was the washington post something
like between nine and 19 unarmed black
men were shot in like 2019 not thousands
like black lives matter was trying to
claim but i'm talking to my friend who
who lives in a you know in the baltimore
area and they were like i don't care
about any of that i want to get rid of
the cops because they keep pulling us
over on bs charges or bs claims and
giving us tickets and i'm like okay i
have no argument for that like what am i
saying i did that and they are having
continued problems i mean philadelphia
that just falls apart
so look
when when people uh
what i hear from like my suburbanite
friends and the police is i got pulled
over for bs reasons and they gave me a
ticket i'm sick of the cops
and maybe that's fine if you're in like
a low crime well-off suburb but then
when you start electing people who are
like yeah we hate cops too and start
gutting them you get what's going on in
portland you get what's going on in new
york you get rampant violent crime you
get what's going on in dc and baltimore
it's all getting worse and then you know
these people who voted for it do they
leave
they leave and they come to your area
and then say okay it's kind of nice here
then they get mad at the way things are
being run and then they vote and get it
again
well portland portland breaks my heart
and
the i did this dual system of justice
where you observed for over a hundred
days i was in an administration during
this
they were just burning stuff down just
breaking stuff down and then
back to our fbi story i think there's a
thread here
it's like the two things i didn't
mention which are on the fbi as well as
like
the the whole gretchen whitmer
thing where
um f10 they had
more fbi informants
trying to kidnap gretchen whitner than
they had
a non-fbi informants and and what was
the motivation behind that they you know
when they broke that story tim i don't
know if you remember but it was in
october early october right before the
election yeah and it was designed
basically to tar
trump it was actually the right brush it
was october surprise and
on the january 6 day we still
don't know just why we had fbi
informants roaming
near the capital some of them on the
grounds that still
goes unexplained but what i do know is
that that violence
um that happened was was
led to trump's impeachment
so i mean
something going on here trump should
have uh
sent in the military during the 2020
riots i thought day two that's something
i told tim actually day two of the riots
i was like he's gotta send in the
national guard what's happening why is
he not stopping this i think i think for
the it's the insurrection he was afraid
more than he looked at as a fascist
don't forget who was the uh secretary of
defense at the time
no it was the mark esper mark millie
show and those guys
turned out to be clowns um just their
you know one of the
one of the tragedies of the first trump
term was all of um
the people who didn't belong there in
powerful positions yeah yeah it
it i i was i i there is a part of me
that's worried about people like millie
you know because i view them as deeply
corrupt and insane individuals but i
also thought about i'm like well they're
cowards too so i really have nothing to
worry about they they they can't do
anything here's why you should worry
they're killing their combat readiness
well that's true though to the extent
that you
uh divert your attention and resources
and organizational culture away from
combat readiness
and the development of the next
generation of defensive weapons to
protect us against russia and china and
instead
go down all the roads they've gone down
um it's it's a very very damaging thing
i mean the the military is in in deep
deep trouble right now morale wise
um combat reading wise readiness-wise
and everything in between and it's
because
of people like millie and and feckless
defense secretaries like esper i mean to
me it's like
esper what the hell why did you keep the
national guard far enough away that they
couldn't be quickly deployed when you
damn well knew that there could be
violence that day is it on purpose well
that's that's
that's the working theory trying to gut
the united st
is that pelosi
uh told the capitol hill police to go
lightly open the barricades under duress
if you needed to the fbi put put
agitators in there and millie
uh and esper kept the national guard far
enough away that they couldn't come to
the rescue in time so that they could
blame trump for whatever happened and
you know they didn't blame trump for
whatever happened and those things
happen so
put it all together
yep
yeah you know like occam's razor the
simplest explanation is usually
the right one and um do you think trump
should have gotten rid of them earlier
do you think he would should have
removed them
there's uh there's an old uh saying in
in
the reagan administration that personnel
is policy right meaning that if you put
the wrong people in you're going to get
the wrong policies reflective of your
administration the taking back trump's
america book takes that a step further
it's that bad personnel not only create
bad policy but bad politics and i go in
though think about trump's american book
i go chapter and verse from the
beginning where we the original sin of
that administration was to get in bed
with the rhinos and then we got like
people like tillerson
at state we got mattis
at defense we had gary cohn goldman
sachs guy of all people leading the
economic policy
inside the white house we lose mike
flynn to the russia hoax russia gate
thing and we wind up with the globalist
hr mcmaster and and which it was just i
mean it's a cabinet of clowns and it's
just
it just really took its toll and at the
back yeah go ahead 5 29.
you remember that
529 yeah the insurrection 529
no what's that the insurrection on 529
when the far left tried storming the
white house and set fire to st john's
church ah yes yeah the 529 insurrection
yes yes see the issue is
there's a subcommittee for that
yeah maybe maybe there should be maybe
there should be
so
donald trump
and law enforcement stopped that
insurrection when they set fire to a
guard post yeah when i think it was what
like 70 was it 70 uh federal agents were
injured in the rioting yeah and more it
was like hundreds total
throughout several days the smoke
all well no the issue was that
this is the way things work and the
victim and victim in
fifth generational warfare i'll put it
that way
on 529 trump stopped an insurrection so
who cares
on 1-6 no one stopped a quote-unquote
insurrection so it's endless news and
instead of blaming law enforcement for
their failure they blame the individuals
who went there and i'm not talking about
the people who are actually violent in
writing by all means you know charge and
arrest those people i'm talking about
the people who walked in confused and
the barricades were up and the doors
were open and didn't see violence and
just were let in by cops taking selfies
with people they get blamed
if donald trump on 529
said to the police and law enforcement
stand down and back off we don't want
anyone getting hurt because we'll get
blamed for it
let those people tear the fences down at
the white house trump would be president
right now
the narrative would be the far left has
gone insane they've crossed the line
they burned down buildings but trump
stopped them so there is no narrative
about far-left violence whenever the far
left was out of control they they punch
people they beat people the media
doesn't cover it the only time there was
ever a really big national story was
when andy noe was brutally beaten in the
street and they had no choice because
the photos were horrific but you see the
right always tries to stop the left from
going out of control and then if the
right ever ever puts one toe over the
line the media screams
screams the top of their lungs
so that's that that's that's that's
that's that it's that simple and i can
only assume
that pelosi and the democrats understand
that
that when you there's a video of a guy
he's watching january 6th happen people
are going in the building and he looks
at the cops he would stop them why
aren't you doing anything and the cops
don't care
they just stand there
makes you wonder not that i know for
sure but i tell you this there were
barely any cops there when there were
hundreds of thousands of people that
were that were down there in dc
why did they let these people do this
there were some cops there trying to
stop them that i get
but seriously the seat of the federal
government could not stop 800 people
from walking through a building
is america that pathetic
that the federal government had no
ability okay if the federal government
is that weak
that pathetic and that ineffective this
country is already doomed 800 people
showed up and we were helpless to stop
them that's the narrative of the january
6 committee that the federal government
has become feckless weak pathetic and
ineffective so my response is okay if
they can't stop 800 people from walking
through a building and they're carrying
sticks maybe we should strip them all of
their funding because it's a big fat
waste of money and then i don't know
what we do hire private companies to
handle security in and around the
district i guess because they certainly
couldn't stop it
amazing huh yeah well i remember after 5
29 2 everyone was like trump got
shuttled to a bunker he's such a coward
like all the media was against this and
it's like what are you talking about we
said all of congress later like a couple
months later and it made sense right
the narrative was that trump was weak
for going to the bunker which is just
security protocol but then we got all
those sound bites from aoc telling us
how terrified she was and someone banged
on her door she made it true yeah well i
mean someone probably banged down her
door but the whole story not like in the
context that she thinks it was though
yeah
you know aoc lied about what happened on
on january 6 she fabricated a story
claiming that i thought i was going to
die because they made it to my office
even though her story happened an hour
before the capital was breached these
people are sick
duplicitous i would argue it is it is
the simpler solution that elements of
the federal government told law
enforcement to back off
as opposed to assuming the federal
government is unable to stop eight
hundred people
that's an issue
two wins and a loss for whoever told the
military to stand down on january's i
mean i was so they were stood down
whether they were ordered to or not i
don't know but they weren't there they
weren't stopping us because they didn't
want the optics of a bunch of military
breaking people's faces getting into
fights opening fire maybe on the crowd
although ashley babbitt was open fire
upon um
they they also would have an opportunity
then to claim like we were being
attacked we need more funding for
defense which is a big win but the
downside is if they actually betrayed us
and didn't defend our capital that's a
big downs that's a big problem and the
idea is i always this is what i always
see in the memes this is what they have
to do they have to conflate anyone who
opposes the democratic establishment and
the uniparty with trump michael malus
and uh
he's a
and dave smith are great examples of
this and it's a meme now that if you
come out and say something about biden
they respond by saying oh yeah but trump
and so you can literally be like
you know biden did a bad job here and
like yeah well trump did a bad job here
and you can go yeah okay i don't care i
don't like trump and they still will
treat you like you're a trump supporter
hunter biden could have the bodies of
children in his basement but trump
economy did you see this sam harrison
you know sam harris podcaster yeah he
said hunter biden could have the corpses
of children in his basement and i would
not care nothing on that laptop would
have changed my mind and then he says
nothing there would be worse than trump
university and that's how deranged
deranged these people are that let's say
the worst case scenario that trump
university all that stuff is all true
that trump had a fake university and
defrauded people oh heavens sure would
be bad but then to ignore the fact that
hunter biden is shown colluding with
foreign interests potentially involving
his father who's the president assuming
samurai saying that's not worse these
people are deranged literally they are
afflicted with something they're out of
their minds
i i think it would be would have been
better
if there was nothing about crack nothing
about sex whatsoever at all on the
hundred biden laptop and allowed us just
to focus on the real pornography which
was the treason to this country i mean
if you i mean i this that thing hit me
so close to home because i spent four
years in the white house trying to get
manufacturing jobs back from china
factories back from china
and hunters going over there leveraging
the power of daddy to get a billion
dollars from the chinese to buy
factories in michigan and ship them back
over there that was the that's the true
obscenity and to your point tim i just
sam here's i don't know who these people
are but i don't the mindset the mindset
is that's the way they think so that's
the way they want everybody else to
think and that's that's how they use the
media they shape they try to shape the
narrative in a way
which conforms with what they want i
think it's the way around i think they
assume that's what other people think
therefore they're saying what they think
they have to say
i think uh it's it's an ends justify the
means
um in the in the taking back trump's
america book there's a whole section
on the media
and the theme about it is daily control
to dominate the news cycle that's if
you're in the white house you understand
that that that's your mission every day
in the white house if you're in the
press corps right you want to dominate
the news cycle in a way which makes your
guy look favorable right
and what we fought every day
was a media willing to take
whatever news there was
and
misinformationalize it you know they put
it in their blender
right and there might be like a story in
in neutral times which would be the
number one story there might be the top
three stories then those wouldn't be the
ones that we'd see every day we'd see
only the ones that would be able to
either put biden in a good light or
trump and a bad light or both
and
to me
it's just it's just an ends justify the
means departure from any kind of
morality or ethics
uh simply to ge and and the funny part
is and it's it's tragic
is they got exactly what they wanted
they got joe biden and he is destroying
everything they don't hold deer but they
don't everything we hold dear and i
guess they don't care i mean
can they not hold social victory above
anything else it's not about a good
economy it's not about having food it's
not about health care it's about saying
i won the day you're talking about
though or the ones that aren't hurt by
this
no no i'm talking about the regular
voters you think there's so look not
every single person obviously but when
when when
i look to the people i know in my life
who voted for for joe biden yeah they
they're they're staring at record gas
prices no remorse no remorse
remember i remember what bill maher are
these people that's what i keep asking
remember what bill maher said yeah if a
recession stops trump bring on a
recession yeah actually calling for pain
and suffering of working-class people
and the best part is right now at the
student debt forgiveness thing seeing
these people on the left be like we need
to get student debt forgiveness it's
about the working class and i'm like bro
college degree holders are not the
working class they're the bourgeoisie
that's what mark's talking about they're
they're the laptop class these people
are the highest income earners in this
country thinking they're the oppressed
minorities it's true though yeah i'll
use that the laptop class well that's
what it is that's what it is that's
exactly right they they think
they're they're deserving of all of this
meanwhile there's a guy who's making
half the salary they get writing
articles about brad pitt's junk and he's
actually doing something for society you
got working-class people who build
things who clean things who fix things
and then you've got people who are like
arts degree holders who are like the
government should they have my debts
yeah okay dude it's not the government
though it's it's me they're asking the
tax exactly to do it when they conflate
the government is paying for it with the
taxpayers they're paying for i get
really annoyed with but i i had an idea
i had an idea i don't think we can can
you continue to function with people who
look i i don't like the idea of people
taking out loans and then being like i'm
not gonna pay them back but i also don't
like the idea of how the interest rates
have made it so that somebody takes out
a thirty thousand dollar loan ends up
paying back a hundred grand that's
insane so here's my idea how about we do
this we'll forgive your loans but you've
got to do four hours per week of
community service at your own discretion
signed off on by a non-profit or a
church we we credit you 50 bucks an hour
for that community service and so long
as you're engaged in that once per week
your loans are frozen and can only go
down how does that sound
it sounds good i still want them to be
able to uh
i think they want to i want them to be
able to make it easier to declare
bankruptcy on student loans that's a
good point too i think the fact that we
tell 18 year olds the only way to
succeed in this country is to get a
degree that's worth an insane amount of
money because we made it so you have to
that's that will cost you right right
thank you
that's not worth chris carr please edit
me live
return on investment tends to be
negative yeah exactly you're gonna have
to pay in the same amount of money the
only way to do that is to go into debt
the second you're an adult
and then we're gonna continue to charge
that forever and by the way there's no
way to get out of this unlike any other
loan like it's just an insane system why
would you ever think this is a good idea
except for the fact that you can trap
people who are desperate to try and
pursue this idea that college gives you
an opportunity which in this country at
this point it really does not it did
until about 2006 when you could study
online maybe before that i just think
that the bachelor's degree is an
oversaturated market and so now we have
to drive everyone to get their masters
which farther in student debt which you
can't declare bankruptcy on and just
goes on and on it's the opposite it's
the opposite actually what happened is
people who have degrees are too
expensive and don't have real world
experience man i saw this when i was 18
and i kept telling my friends it's a
trap but they didn't believe me now
they're all really angry that they can't
pay off their debt but it's this simple
if if ian comes to me and he's like i
make music i say okay okay and prove
that you can make music and he goes
here's a piece of paper signed off on by
an expensive institution that says i
learned how to make music
what am i supposed to do with that
some homeless guy could walk up i make
music and i'll bet prove it to me and
they'll go
a farm and i oh
well he's singing he's a good singer too
that's more valuable to me than your
certified piece of paper yeah i mean the
joke is online that you get your
bachelor's degree and then you apply for
an entry level job and they're like do
you have five years of professional
experience because it doesn't mean
anything but think about the kind of
person you'd have to be to walk into
that trap
trusting and that's unfortunate that
there's a lot of people who are going
this is why i'm like we need to find a
solution to this but i certainly do not
respect the entitlement of so many of
these people i'm i'm not comfortable
with charging taxpayers money to pay
back sallie mae for people's loans i do
not want to do that again they did in
2008 obama paid back and bailed those
companies out and i do not want to bail
them out again in the guise of a loan
repayment
if they want to
negate sallie mae's books and say hey
you you're worth 580 billion less now
and no these people are not giving you
that 10 grand back each that's another
story whether or not a bankrupt sally
may i don't know
maybe that's not even the worst thing
i'm sure they would say oh that would
destroy the entire economy if you
bankrupted sallie mae we can't allow
that we need to bankrupt you instead i
don't like it what is your thoughts i
mean you're an economist what
what are your thoughts on this
if you're uh if you're going to go to
college these days um
you might want to think about stem stem
education science technology
it's it's the key to getting a decent
job
um
the the liberal arts
okay liberal arts of the liberal arts i
majored in english i'm okay with saying
it's not a key way i got i think
what you want to do right now
to educate yourself is download a
survival guide
learn how to raise livestock
and some rudimentary you know
engineering because uh even mark ruffalo
in an interview about whether or not
he's gonna be the hulk he was like well
the way things are going hopefully i'm
still around and there's a world that
can [ __ ] you know exist to do this so
even he's kind of thinking maybe this is
all going to implode and the world's
going to end i mean the paradigm has
shifted with the with the access to
online education i remember back when i
was at university of california irvine
teaching back in the 90s i was actually
one of the first
pioneers of online education back then
and the the
the
people inside the university were
totally again it because it it basically
it just
ups it gave directs access to students
in a cheap way and it threatened the
whole
tenure paradigm and things like that and
so i think today there's a lot less need
for the kind of four-year college thing
that people do i mean just go because
there's so much you can learn
online
uh and be done with that but and i
always felt bad that these people would
take on these huge loans i mean it's in
a lot of ways it's a scam and you know
my professor elites
i mean we had it pretty good right you
know you you kick back and you don't pay
as much attention to teaching as you
should and things like that um i'd see
this among my colleagues
just i mean we're not we didn't do
the academy did has not done its duty
to our young people and we get what we
get yeah it's it's it's you know you
folks i mean i'm talking i'm i'm an old
guy i'm talking to a very young
demographic here
it's a very different world you're
growing up in you know back back when i
was your age
uh we had we had the dream know we could
get get the good job the the the picket
fence the house the car and this that
and the other thing
and um
that's that's both not within reach for
a lot of people and really not their
dream anymore which is interesting in
and of itself i went to an antique store
they had an old radio is very very big
it was like three and a half feet tall
yeah two feet wide and the knobs on it
were like tiny and there was a wheel
that would click you know to like you're
spinning through the frequencies or
whatever and the funny thing is i
thought about i'm like
when this thing was sold the guy who
sold it that was all he did he worked
quite literally at a radio store and he
fed a family of four he had two cars
and he went on vacations and all he did
was sell radios to people yeah now
that's crazy huh yeah today both parents
are working full-time and neither can
afford anything yeah
yeah no it's um
and look the the concern i have as an
economist and as somebody who is
concerned about the prosperity of this
country
is whatever our educational system is
today it's simply not delivering
competitive individuals in a global
marketplace i mean it's just not no it's
not it's just not and um
we spend more on education i think than
any country in the world and we we get
less but would you say that our
education is overpriced i mean i think
there are no questions so many things
to cut down on it we really wanted to
have everyone graduate from college i
think the only reason why they do the
four-year thing is because there's a
football season or something like that i
mean yeah because the first two years
you spend doing general credits
there needs to be the total revolution
in education
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there
you